У депутатів Верховної Ради добра зарплата натлі мінімальної, але недостатня.
Так вважає голова партії "Слуга народу" і, як прогнозують,
новий спікер парламенту Дмитро Разумков.
В одному з інтерв’ю він сказав, що Україна тільки йде "дотого,
щомають, наприклад, європейські депутати- гідна зарплата і хороший соціальний пакет,
коли людина тримається зацюроботу і розуміє її престиж".
DW вирішила розібратися, скільки нині заробляють народні обранці
і наскільки виправдано підвищувати їхню зарплатню.
У середньому народні обранці в Україні отримують щомісяця до 40 тисяч гривень "брутто",
тобто до вираховування податків.
Зарплата депутатів вираховується за формулою, в основі якої - прожитковий мінімум.
Тобто коли він зростає - зростають і зарплати депутатів.
Крім того, суми різняться залежно від різноманітних доплат і надбавок,
скажімо, за науковий ступінь, інтенсивність праці і так далі.
Формула нарахування депутатам зарплатні настільки складна і заплутана,
що ці суми можуть мало не вдвічі різнитися від місяця до місяця.
У відповіді апарату Верховної Ради на запит інформагентства "Українські новини",
приміром, за березень цього року найбільшу зарплату серед усіх депутатів
отримала народна обранка від БПП Ольга Богомолець - майже 49 з половиною тисяч гривень.
При цьому в нинішнього спікера Андрія Парубія було 46 тисяч гривень,
а в його першої заступниці Ірини Геращенко - 48 з половиною тисяч.
А от уже у липні Геращенко заробила майже вдвічі більше, ніж Парубій - понад 72 тисячі гривень.
Окрім зарплати, депутати щомісяця отримують ще майже по 38 з половиною тисяч гривень.
Це так звані "нараховані кошти, пов’язані з виконанням депутатських повноважень".
Зокрема на оплату роботи помічників і приймалень.
Також компенсується проїзд та проживання для депутатів з інших міст.
Тож, загалом у багатьох народних обранців виходить понад 100 тисяч гривень на місяць.
Найбільше в Євросоюзі заробляють італійські депутати - по над 10 тисяч євро на місяць.
Це майже в п’ять разів більше, ніж середня зарплата в країні.
Крім того, держава оплачує їм навіть похід до перукаря.
Одна з найбільших зарплат у ЄС і в німецьких парламентаріїв -
9 з половиною тисяч євро до сплати податків.
Це плюс-мінус втричі більше за середню зарплату.
Плюс щомісяця німецькі депутати отримують понад чотири тисячі євро
для компенсації службових витрат: від оренди житла до транспортних видатків.
У Польщі ж депутати отримують понад дві тисячі євро.
Порівняно із середньою зарплатою в країні це вдвічі більше.
Дискусії та спекуляції щодо депутатських зарплат в Україні
щоразу постають перед виборами та прийняттям бюджету.
Одні депутати й експерти запевняють, що зарплати надто низькі, і це одна з головних причин корупції.
Інші вважають, що політика і Верховна Рада не можуть бути місцем збагачення,
а нинішніх зарплат більш ніж достатньо, що мати гідний рівень життя.
Якщо порівнювати зарплати українських законотворців
з доходами пересічних українців - різниця величезна.
За даними Держстату за червень,
середня зарплата в Україні становить близько 11 тисяч гривень за місяць.
Це вдесятеро менше порівняно із зарплатою народних обранців разом із доплатами і пільгами.
Водночас якщо порівнювати з підприємницьким сектором в Україні - зарплати нардепів нижчі.
Деякі новачки у парламенті, які до виборів працювали, приміром, у шоу-бізнесі,
тепер на ставці депутата справді отримуватимуть менше.
Нині обговорюється також компромісний варіант - підвищити зарплату депутатів,
але при цьому позбавити їх імунітету і посилити їхнє покарання за хабарництво та інші злочини.
У партії "Слуга народу", яка у новій Раді сформує монобільшість, ще немає чіткого розуміння,
що робити з депутатськими зарплатами. Розглядаються різні варіанти.
Зокрема не підвищення зарплати, а запровадження бонусної системи
залежно від ефективності роботи депутата, його відвідувань засідань Ради,
законотворчої діяльності та інших показників.